allez on s'évade de l'autre côté de
l'océan Indien direction le kazulu Natal
près de Durban et son givagorge Mountain
by Park un parc comme en rêve tous les
bikers pays pas moins d'une dizaine de
pistes et itinéraires pour tous les
goûts et tous les niveaux ça nous
donnerait presque envie de vacances
sportives pas très loin d'ici pas vous
voilà ce qui nous manque à la Réunion
il est vraiment fantastique comme vous
pouvez le voir derrière moi on y
pratique aussi bien le BMX que le
freeride et le montagne bike il y a
plein de parcours différents très bien
entretenus et la plupart des locaux
viennent s'entraîner ici même les
équipes pros
derrière moi il y a aussi la piste de
descente ça ouvre vraiment des
opportunités pour tout le monde quel que
soit ta discipline
personnellement je viens ici faire du
Mont time bike parce qu'on peut
s'entraîner techniquement en rocher en
descente on peut traverser des rivières
et il y a tout ce dont on a besoin pour
s'améliorer
comme vous pouvez le voir d'autres
préfèrent le BMX parce que c'est plus
court plus rapide c'est un peu moins
difficile
vérifie
car elle est très dangereuse et il faut
bien sûr des équipements spéciaux
est un parc très populaire auprès des
habitants du quad Zulu natal mais aussi
les gens viennent ici depuis
Johannesburg Captain ou encore dirt ban
pour passer des vacances et rider c'est
un endroit sûr il y a tout pour tout le
monde même pour les jeunes enfants qui
peuvent rider jusqu'au cascades et
revenir
en plus ici ils emploient des locaux qui
vous emmène faire le tour du parc quand
vous ne connaissez pas l'endroit il vous
accompagne pour rider c'est pour ça que
c'est très populaire